I want to talk about touka and birdy the
animated Netflix show and how it uses a
sex scene to do everything the Fifty
Shades wishes it could have done but
first I'm going to just shove in a
super-short lukewarm defense of
gratuitous sex scenes because I don't
want to give the impression that this is
like the only correct way to do things I
have spent a pretty substantial amount
of time talking about the Fifty Shades
franchise but in all that time I've not
really spent much of it discussing most
of the sex scenes beyond acknowledging
that they exist a big reason for that is
that with few exceptions of the scenes
don't really do anything this is not a
new criticism of course plenty of people
have pointed out that the Fifty Shades
sack scenes largely exist in bubble
space things stopped sex happens things
move on
they are scenes that can be pretty
cleanly excised from different markets
without having a meaningful impact on
the films they just don't have a lot of
purpose now this is probably something
you've heard before but let's actually
dig into that for a second what gives a
sex scene purpose I'm going to argue
however briefly a much more permissive
interpretation of this purpose is a
narrative construct and it exists in
that context it is characterization it
is world building it is theme it is plot
but it's also pacing and aesthetic
fulfillment looking good and breaking up
the action or drama for a couple minutes
as a narrative exhale are a good enough
purpose not every scene in every movie
needs to be deep to justify its
existence fun is an acceptable aesthetic
goal where Fifty Shades ends up really
falling flat is that the sex scenes are
not only isolated from plot and theme
and character they're also repetitive
overly long not particularly
good-looking and generally unmemorable
basically the nominal value as aesthetic
or pacing are undercut by not having a
good aesthetic and killing the pacing
okay so let's talk about a sex scene
that's the complete opposite of all of
that
Tuukka and Bertie is a 2019 Netflix
original animated sitcom created by
illustrator writer and
cartoonist Lisa Hanawalt the series
revolves around the titular characters
touka and birdy as they navigate the
complexities of adulthood touka is a
fun-loving carefree directionless
catastrophe living off her rich aunts
goodwill while dealing with hidden pain
and trauma and birdy is a nervous
career-minded data analyst and aspiring
baker dealing with hidden pain and
trauma the scene I want to focus on
comes from the third episode the deli
guy since her long-term boyfriend
speckle moved in with her birdy feels
like their sex life has grown routine
and uninteresting which she
catastrophize --is as the seed of a
chain reaction of resentment that will
eventually ruin her life parallel to
this birdy has been developing a sexual
interest in pace to repeat an
authoritative dominating older celebrity
pastry chef to spice things up she
suggests that she and speckle try
something new what if you I don't know
ordered me around speckle suggests a
safe word birdy brushes the suggestion
off because she wants to look cool and
strong and the roleplay begins
maybe something like bend over you
little tart okay at first things are
going well but they quickly take a turn
for the worse after speckle calls birdy
a bad bird triggering an intensely
negative reaction as birdy breaks down
speckle uses his warm potato safeword to
end things and the two of them agree to
just go with the usual for the night
usual way usual wait now this scene is
brilliant
while this specific interaction never
comes up again in the season the
characters never try again or really
talk about what it means the themes
underlying this scene form a thesis
statement for the season as a whole
speckle crosses Birdy's limits pushes
her boundaries but doesn't do so out of
neglect or ballast or ego he crosses
those lines because he doesn't know
they're there and he doesn't know where
Birdy's lines are because birdy doesn't
know where Birdy's lines are I didn't
think I'd react this way what the hell
and it's important to emphasize that
these lines aren't cleanly drawn when
Beco calls birdie at art and starts
spanking her she's super into it
what birdie doesn't understand about
herself is that she likes the idea of
submission but only in the context of
validation and ends up confronting that
about herself the hard way by accident
but I'm a good speckle wants to respect
birdies boundaries but he can't do that
if she doesn't know what they are this
then is the thesis statement that
underpins the season that we don't often
know what our boundaries are until we
hit them whether it be in matters of sex
family friends co-living or any other
relationship over the course of the
season all the characters confront this
realization that they need to get to
know themselves better so that they can
actually communicate their wants and
needs with the people who love them as
the season goes on the stakes of these
conflicts escalate touka needs to
confront her history of substance abuse
and her toxic relationship with her aunt
birdee needs to confront the ways that
childhood abuse has echoed through her
life speckle comes face to face with the
possibility that no matter how much he
loves her
his emotional needs where he wants his
life to go might be incompatible with
staying together with birdy the show
does a really fantastic job of getting
into the chaotic mess of being an adult
and be give and take required to
navigate relationships where both people
are willing participants who have their
own complicated wants and needs where
some boundaries are big and obvious and
others are really detailed and touchy
sometimes between people those needs
line up and sometimes they're mutually
exclusive and maybe we don't even
entirely understand them ourselves all
of us need to compromise and in turn ask
others to compromise for us navigating
that space between ourselves is not a
clean process and may in fact be deeply
painful
there are things we're willing to
compromise on because it will make
someone else happy and making them happy
will make us happier than keeping the
thing we compromised
and there are other lines that we have
to ask others to never cross spaces that
we have to ask others to give up and the
worst part is that we may not even know
where those lines and spaces are until
it's too late and we've stumbled into
them by accident
all of this touka and birdy manages to
touch on in 192nd sex scene and honestly
I don't think you could do the same this
efficiently without that aspect without
it being a sex scene and without the
vulnerability that represents and that's
what I think really makes this scene
stand out see well I will defend the
gratuitous and trivial for indulging in
aesthetic satiation above metaphorical
pursuits this type of interaction one
that doesn't just have sex as the
backdrop for things to happen in front
of but uses the dynamics of intimacy for
their intrinsic qualities it is
exemplary storytelling this is a scene
that couldn't exist in another context
Birdy's relationship with her own
sexuality the frame of power dynamics
and the specific boundary of being
punished in that space if you were to D
sex the scene the meaning would change
entirely this scene takes on heavy
implications in later episodes when
birdy begins working with pastry Pete
who forces her into an uncomfortable
situation with clear sexual undertones a
moment that exploits birdie zone in
confidence in her boundaries which
spirals into birdie making terrible
mistakes that place others in harm's way
to throw this back to Fifty Shades one
last time taken as a whole this
effectively demonstrates the difference
between consenting adults exploring
power dynamics and their own wants and
needs and abuse and does so in a way
that Fifty Shades never really managed
to do even when it tried at the end of
the deli I speckle listens to birdy she
does want him to be in charge but in the
vein of a Victorian bodice Ripper to
sweep her off her feet with big
melodramatic declarations to be adored
but even this comes back later lay
in the season speckle and birdie toy
with the idea of buying a house and
moving out of their one-bedroom
apartment birdie at one point has a
major meltdown and disappears for
several days out of town during which
speckled can't get a hold of her because
she refuses to answer his calls and then
loses her phone in a lake speckle then
buys a fixer-upper house when a sudden
opportunity presents itself well he
thought that she would be on board with
this spontaneous move the stress of her
vanishing and going incommunicado turns
it into an arguments just be your rock
all the time wait what speckle needs to
confront both birdy and himself and
admit that while he hoped it would make
her happy he wants to move on with his
life
he hopes that she'll come with him but
if she can't if their needs have
diverged then it'll be sad but this is
what he needs to move forward managing
relationships navigating compromises
it's a lot of work and it's not easy but
as touka and birdy argues it's worth it
we need that human contact we need those
support networks flawed and human as
they may be because we can't make it
alone
[Music]